e
ça allait être terrible, il y a
les y avoir une explosion de la
consommation.
Jacques Farcy, président et
chef de la direction de la SQDC.
Est-ce que c'est un succès
d'après vous?
- Je pense que le système
Nous avons une mission qui est
très importante pour le Québec,
protection de la santé.
On a fait tout ça dans un cadre
Québec, parce qu'on est capable
de livrer des profits à la
société québécoise.
- On va prendre ça une chose à
la fois.
Mais on va commencer avec la
question de la crainte,rt
était que les jeunes consomment
davantage. Or, il y a eu une
augmentation quand
15 ans et plus. C'est tout le
monde.
En 2018,7 et 14 %, en 2021, a
augmentévous dîtevous dîtevous e
étude sur la base déclarative.
peut-être plus
complexés.
- Vous avez dit, on a réussi
à aller chercher du marché noir
une partie importante du marché.
Vous dites, en fait on dit que
vous avez 58 % du marché.
Moi, ça me semble assez
optimiste.
Vous avez vraiment été capable
d'aller chercher 58 % du marché?
- Le chiffre le plus important
c'est le tonnage.
La nuit dernière on a passé
prêt de 110...
pour savoir le pourcentage, il
faut le rapporter au total.
Quand on fait le r 110
t que nous avons vendues
sur la taille estimée du marché,
c'est lous avons les
58 %.
- 110 tonnes.
C'est imans les
extraits présentés avant, que ça
Le marché noir s'est adapté, ils
vendent moins cher, ils sont
s. marché, il y a le 28 g,
l'once.Sur ce sSur ce sSur ce s,
le marché noir offre des rabaise
pas sur le marché noir.
En revanche, sur le... gramm
on a des prix très intéress
sécurisés.
- Est-ce que ce n'est pas ça la
grande avancée?
Parce que il y a plus de
consommateurs. Ç
études.
faudrait que chez les jeunes,
les études montrent que ça a
baissé,
Donc vou ça?
- Tout à fait. Tout à fait.
rappelle, c'est vraiment
la seule destination légale duei
Donc effectivement, nos produits
Et vous êtes certain de la
qualité de ce que vous êtes en
train d'acheter.
jeunes à commencer à consommer.
- On est dans une logique
d'offrir accès à des produits
contrôlés, mais
commerçant ordinai
stimuler.
du marché illégal vers le marché
légal. Sans proposer de
consomme
- Le gou
argent avec vous. On va le voir
sur le tut.
ue c'est plus
élevé.
- Année dernière on est passé
sur 70 millions,delà...us de 70i
sont versés au gouvernementmodèt
argent avait un usageparticuliet
versé avec un usage particuliere
cannabis et également la lut
Il est besoin de recherche
autour du cannabis.
- On réinvestit largement pour
lutter contre les dépendance
Est-ce que vous voulez
accessible?
Je sais que vous ne le faite
pas...
- oui, on fait la livraison.
Vous avez trois types de
livraison.
La livraison standard, donc le
lendemain par Post
On a également une livraisondsds
centres, comme Montréal, Québec.
- Mon Dieu, que je suis dépassé!
- Et la livraison à 90 minutes
qu'on est en train de tester.
- Non, on est sur une logique de
peut
fonctionner et répondre auxdes .
Intéressés des coursiers?ne coms
livraison. On s'assure dedemand.
- Et on va demander au chauffeur
de ne pas consommer des
substances à bord.- Oui on s'ast
bien fait.
- Est-ce qu'on doit goûter
produits, vous en avalez, vous
en cuisinez?
- Non je ne suis pas
consommateur.
- Zéro? Vous n'avez pas de
curiosité?
- Je suis très curieux sur le
cannabis, je me documente
énormément, mais j
pas. Ce qu'on dit à nos clients,
c'est de ne pas en consommer.
- Vous étiez à la SAQ avant?
Vous buviez du vin avant?
- Je dégustais du vin,
et quand j'en dégustais, je
st
pas la même chose avec le
cannabis., en fait, le
gouvernement a décidé au Québec
de ne pas faire des gélules, des
bonbons, rien qui ressemble à
des bonbons. Ça, ça ne bougera
pas?
- C'est dans la loi.
Les comestibles solides ne
peuvent pas être des produits
attractifs pour les jeunes.
Ce sont des produits qu'on
propose depuis le 5 avril,plusi,
et qui sont un peu surprenantes
au démarrage, mais
leur public aujourd'hui.
- Monsieur Farcy, merci
beaucoup. Vous allez peut-être
essayer, adopter. Des questions
de santé qui font
avez pas envie?
- Je n'en ressens pas le besoin.
- C'est